Let's go to, let's go to our caller from the
eight Oh seven area code.
Who's calling today from eight zero seven.
Oh hi David.
My name is Clint.
I'm calling from uh, Canada.
Hey Clint.
What's up?
Um, I just want to get your thoughts of today's
situations and, uh, I find that a lot of like
America is quite paranoid,
paranoid of like, well, well
for just any kind of situation that's happening
in the current States right now, like say
the Corona virus where you have like, I, and
I know that you've, you have debated with
Jesse Lee Peterson and I do listen to him
just because it's like, you know, it's like
a car wreck.
You can't look away.
Sure, sure.
Um, but, and then, you know, the, just the
rhetoric, a lot of the right uses is it just
seems quite to be paranoid where he uses terms
as you know, um, um, the immigrant virus or
you know, like, uh, the illegal alien sickness
and all that.
And same with like a Steven Crowder as well.
Uh, I just want to get your thoughts on that.
Yeah.
This is not, your observation is accurate
in that in the United States, a lot of right
wing political ideology is motivated by fear
of different kinds and uh, warnings about
violence, infections, dirtiness in morality
or whatever.
Right?
So there's a lot of, you know, anti-abortion
based on the fear of going to hell and that
you're killing a person if you go and get
an abortion, we need to stop immigration because
as Tucker Carlson said, immigrants will make
our country dirtier and poorer and they bring
disease and all sorts of stuff.
So there's a lot, a lot of that is moralizing
around cleanliness and there's a lot of religious
stuff that's wrapped up in that that could
be studied.
And then also just generally fear-mongering.
We need a strong president who's going to
be aggressive to other countries because that's
what will keep us safe.
Otherwise we'll get attacked.
It's a very common theme of how the right
wing operates.
Yeah, it's very, yeah, it's very common.
Like, and just, I've, cause I, I work in the
tourist industry help here and we, like most
of our client calls are American.
Interesting and a lot a lot of like, like,
don't get me wrong.
There's a lot of good, there's a lot of good
ones.
But then there, you know, you get those, you
get those ones that are, you can tell like
they're definitely right wing.
Yeah.
And you, it's, it's like, it's almost like,
it almost turned into like, just this really
paranoia of, you know, all like, and also
like, uh, a lot of what ifs.
Like what if this, what if that wall, you
can say that about anything.
Right.
Um, you know, like, and I, and I, I, and I
noticed Steven Crowder uses that a lot and
you know, and then these people have really
big followings and, and sometimes I just feel
that the rhetoric is, it is, it is quite dangerous.
Yup.
It's dangerous.
It's fear-based and unfortunately it works
on a lot of people to a great degree.
A Clint from Canada.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate your call and I hope to hear
from you again in the future.